This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In the 1920s, a young Englishman was stationed in Burma, now Myanmar, working as an officer in the Indian Imperial Police Force. Early one morning, he got a phone call. An elephant was ravaging the bazaar. Would he please come and do something about it? Arriving at the bazaar, the officer learned that the elephant had killed a man and damaged a bamboo hut. He asked for a rifle in case he needed to defend himself.
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。20世纪20年代，一位年轻的英国人被派往缅甸（现为缅甸联邦共和国），在印度帝国警察部队担任警官。一天清晨，他接到一个电话。一头大象正在集市上横冲直撞。对方请求他过去处理一下。警官赶到集市后得知，这头大象已经踩死了一个人，并毁坏了一间竹屋。他要了一支步枪，以防需要自卫。
Once he began to make his way toward the animal, weapon in hand, a crowd of villagers began gathering around him, shouting excitedly. The officer didn't want to shoot the elephant. He didn't think to shoot the elephant. He didn't think shooting the elephant was necessary. But standing there, surrounded by some 2,000 villagers, he felt that he no longer had a choice. In his words,
当他手持武器向那头动物走去时，一群村民开始围拢过来，兴奋地大喊大叫。这位警官并不想射杀大象。他没想过要射杀大象。他认为射杀大象并无必要。但站在那里，被大约2000名村民包围着，他感到自己已别无选择。用他的话来说，
Suddenly I realized I should have to shoot the elephant after all. The people expected it of me, and I had got to do it. I could feel their 2,000 will wheels pressing me forward irresistibly. To come all that way, rifle in hand, with 2,000 people marching at my heels, and then to trail feebly away having done nothing? No, that was impossible. The essay, Shooting an Elephant, was published in 1936 by the British writer George Orwell. It's a dramatic rendering of a widely shared experience. We often encounter pressure from others to do things.
突然我意识到，我终究还是得射杀这头大象。人们期待我这么做，我必须得做。我能感觉到他们那2000个人的意志之轮正不可抗拒地推着我向前。大老远赶来，手里拿着步枪，身后跟着2000人，然后却什么也没做就灰溜溜地走开？不，那是不可能的。这篇名为《射象》的文章由英国作家乔治·奥威尔于1936年发表。这是对一种普遍经历的戏剧性呈现。我们经常会遇到来自他人的压力，要求我们去做某些事情。
Do we comply, compromise, or Resist. This week on Hidden Brain, how to navigate the demands of other people while staying true to ourselves. Living among other people, holding down a job, raising children, cultivating friendships, means that you feel a never-ending stream of requests, invitations, and orders. Your boss wants you to take on an assignment. Your kid's teacher needs volunteers. Your friend asks you for a favor. How do we respond to all these demands on our time and energy? At the University of Houston, Vanessa Patrick studies the psychology of how we respond to these requests and how we can align what we do with what we really want to do.
我们是顺从、妥协，还是反抗？本周的《Hidden Brain》，探讨如何在保持自我的同时应对他人的要求。生活在人群中，保住一份工作，抚养孩子，维系友谊，意味着你会感受到源源不断的请求、邀请和命令。老板想让你承担一项任务。孩子的老师需要志愿者。朋友请你帮忙。我们该如何应对所有这些对我们时间和精力的要求？在休斯顿大学，凡妮莎·帕特里克研究了我们如何应对这些请求的心理学，以及我们如何将自己的行为与内心真正想做的事情保持一致。
Vanessa Patrick, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar, for having me. Vanessa, I understand that you started out your career working at an advertising agency in India. At the end of one particular workday, you were looking forward to leaving the office and going home to a celebration. What were you celebrating? What had you planned? Shankar, for most people, 24th birthdays are somewhat unremarkable. However, for mine, it stands out in time because of this incident that happened at this advertising
凡妮莎·帕特里克，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你，尚卡尔，很高兴来到这里。凡妮莎，我了解到你的职业生涯始于印度的一家广告公司。在某一个工作日的下班时间，你本期待着离开办公室回家参加庆祝活动。你在庆祝什么？你计划了什么？尚卡尔，对大多数人来说，24岁生日并没有什么特别之处。然而，对我而言，它在时间长河中显得格外突出，因为在那家广告公司发生了一件事，
agency, which was my first job. It was a routine day. We had client meetings and I was the junior most person at the advertising agency. And so as part of the team, when the team met the client, what we would do is we would have a discussion about what the plans were, what ads we were going to develop, briefs, et cetera. And I was in charge of writing the minutes, which were the notes of the meeting. I had to type those minutes up, fax them to the client, and the client would then respond back, saying, the minutes are received and they are OK.
那是我第一份工作。那是平常的一天。我们有客户会议，而我是广告公司里资历最浅的人。所以作为团队的一员，当团队会见客户时，我们会讨论计划是什么，我们要开发什么样的广告，简报等等。我负责写会议纪要，也就是会议记录。我必须把这些纪要打印出来，传真给客户，然后客户会回复说，纪要已收到，没问题。
And so this was a routine task. I did it every day. Now, on that particular day, I was in a huge rush to finish the minutes and head home because I had a big party planned and people were coming over to celebrate my birthday with me, family and friends. So I got them typed, showed them to my boss
这本是一项例行公事。我每天都做。然而，就在那天，我急着完成纪要然后回家，因为我计划了一个大型派对，亲朋好友都要来为我庆祝生日。所以我把它们打印出来，给老板看了看，
and faxed the minutes over, ready to leave at 5 p.m., ready to beat the rush hour traffic. I was getting ready to walk to the elevator and my boss comes to my cubicle to inquire whether I had sent the minutes over. And I said yes. And then she turned around and walked to the elevator. And then she turned back and I thought she was going to say, hey Vanessa, have a great party. Enjoy your evening with the friends. But what she said instead was, have you received the facts from the client
并把纪要传真了过去，准备下午5点下班，避开高峰期的交通。我正准备走向电梯，老板来到我的隔间询问我是否已经把纪要发过去了。我说发了。然后她转身走向电梯。接着她又转过身来，我以为她会说，嘿，凡妮莎，祝你派对愉快。和朋友们度过一个愉快的夜晚。但她说的却是，你收到客户发来的传真，
saying that they have received the minutes? And that was not what I anticipated that she was going to ask. And so I said, no. So she said, well, don't leave till you receive that fax. My plans for the evening were shattered with that instruction. And I was just shell shocked, stunned. She turned around and went home. And I was left with the burden of having to wait for a fax that I had no idea when that was going to come and potentially
说他们已经收到纪要了吗？那不是我预料中她会问的问题。所以我说，没有。于是她说，好吧，没收到传真之前别走。那条指令让我的晚间计划彻底破灭了。我当时简直惊呆了，不知所措。她转身回家了。而我却背负着必须等待一份不知道何时才会来的传真的重担，并可能
miss my birthday party. So I considered all sorts of options. Should I leave anyway and then come early and put it on her desk or should I ask a friend to handle it? But I was so scared. It was my first job. I was so afraid that if I didn't do this task, I could be fired that I called home and I said, I'm late. I'm going to be late. And as the evening progressed, everybody from the office started leaving and I was staring at the fax machine waiting for the fax to come. I kept calling home and somebody from my family, either my dad, my mom, or one of my sisters would pick up the phone and say,
错过我的生日派对。所以我考虑了各种选择。我是应该不管怎样先走，然后早点来把它放在她桌上，还是应该请朋友帮忙处理？但我太害怕了。这是我的第一份工作。我非常担心如果不完成这项任务，我可能会被解雇，所以我打电话回家说，我迟到了。我要晚点回去。随着夜晚的推移，办公室里的人开始陆续离开，我盯着传真机等待传真到来。我不断地给家里打电话，我的家人，要么是我爸爸，要么是我妈妈，或者我姐妹中的一个会接电话说，
yeah, this friend has come and this friend has left. And essentially it was a Tuesday evening, so it had to be an early night. By about 9 p.m., the fax did arrive. I picked the fax up from the fax machine and I put it on my boss's desk and I went home. And what, how many friends were still left when you got home? Actually just my grandmother. My grandmother was the only one who stayed on and waited to wish me. Everyone else had left because it was a Tuesday evening and they needed
是的，这个朋友来了，那个朋友走了。基本上那天是周二晚上，所以必须早点结束。大约晚上9点，传真终于到了。我从传真机上取下传真，把它放在老板的桌上，然后回家了。那么，当你到家时还有多少朋友在？其实只有我祖母。我祖母是唯一留下来等我并祝我生日快乐的人。其他人都走了，因为那是周二晚上，他们需要
to get back home for work or for school. So many years later Vanessa, you became a professor at the University of Houston and in that role you fielded many requests for your time and one was an invitation to join a committee that would decide on the winner of a prestigious award. What was your first reaction to this invitation? I didn't want to do it. Being on these committees is a service engagement which takes a lot of time and I just did not want to do it. I have my plate full, I have tons of work, I didn't know how to fit it in. And yet, I did feel that there was some value in being on the committee, that I was asked, that I was special in some way perhaps, and I thought, okay, maybe I should just say yes.
赶回家工作或上学。多年后，凡妮莎，你成为了休斯顿大学的教授，在这个职位上，你收到了许多占用你时间的请求，其中一个是邀请你加入一个委员会，决定一个著名奖项的获得者。你对这个邀请的第一反应是什么？我不想做。参加这些委员会是一种服务性工作，非常耗时，我根本不想做。我已经忙得不可开交，有大量的工作，我不知道该怎么挤出时间。然而，我确实觉得加入委员会是有价值的，既然被邀请了，也许我在某种程度上很特别，我想，好吧，也许我应该答应。
So you joined this committee and then along the way you discover something unexpected. What was it? Through an unfortunate series of events, I discovered a set of emails that was accidentally forwarded to me on all the people who were considered to be on this committee. I also saw a back and forth on debating who was going to be asked, and I was number nine on their choice list. After I found that out, it really diminished my enthusiasm and I felt very resentful towards the people who had asked me and really kicked myself for saying yes when I wanted to say no. Hmm so in other words not only did you say yes when you wanted to say no but you realized that you are the backup to the backup to the
所以你加入了这个委员会，然后在过程中你发现了一些意想不到的事情。是什么？通过一系列不幸的事件，我发现了一组被意外转发给我的电子邮件，内容是关于所有被考虑加入该委员会的人选。我还看到了他们关于邀请谁的来回辩论，而我在他们的候选名单上排在第九位。发现这一点后，我的热情大减，我对那些邀请我的人感到非常愤恨，并为自己明明想拒绝却答应了而感到懊恼。嗯，换句话说，你不仅在想拒绝时说了“是”，而且你还意识到你是备选的备选的
backup to the backup. Nine times over yes. In addition to all the demands from our workplaces, many of us have people in our personal lives who need our time and energy. A friend of yours once reached out with an urgent request for help concerning groceries. Tell me the situation. What happened, Vanessa? Yes. So Shankar, we are all good people, and I think I'm a good person. And so when someone is in need, I feel the need to help them. So in this particular story, I heard that a friend of mine was very close to delivering her baby,
备选的备选。九次之多，是的。除了工作中的各种要求，我们许多人的个人生活中也有需要我们时间和精力的人。你的一位朋友曾向你发出紧急请求，希望你在购买杂货方面提供帮助。告诉我当时的情况。发生了什么，凡妮莎？是的。尚卡尔，我们都是好人，我想我也是个好人。所以当有人需要帮助时，我感到有必要帮助他们。在这个故事中，我听说我的一位朋友快要生孩子了，
heavily pregnant, on bed rest. And I called her up asking how she was feeling and to cheer her up. And before I ended the call, I politely offered to help if there was anything that she needed. Not a very long time later, she emailed me and said, can you please pick up groceries for me today? And she sent me a long list of groceries
怀孕后期，正在卧床休息。我打电话给她询问她的感觉，并安慰她。在挂断电话之前，我礼貌地提出如果她有什么需要，我可以帮忙。没过多久，她给我发邮件说，你今天能帮我买些杂货吗？她发给我一份很长的杂货清单，
and the grocery store to pick it up from please pick up groceries for me today. And she sent me a long list of groceries and the grocery store to pick it up from with very specific instructions. And that was not very convenient. She didn't ask me if I had the time and I had to juggle a fair bit. And I dashed across town to pick up groceries from that particular store.
以及购买杂货的商店，请今天帮我买些杂货。她发给我一份很长的杂货清单，并指定了购买的商店，还有非常具体的说明。这很不方便。她没问我是否有时间，我不得不费了一番周折。我匆忙赶到城里那家特定的商店去买杂货。
I walk into the house laden with groceries, and I see her husband sitting in the backyard, kicking back with a beer. And there was something about that experience that just made me mad. Like I am running around getting groceries out of the goodness of my heart for this friend. And she could have easily asked her husband who's sitting right in the backyard and the
我提着杂货走进她家，看到她丈夫坐在后院，悠闲地喝着啤酒。那种经历让我感到非常生气。我出于好心为这位朋友四处奔波买杂货。而她本可以轻易地让坐在后院的丈夫去买，而且
grocery store was so five minutes away from their house. So I think that definitely affected my relationship with my friend. with my friend. Like many of us, Vanessa found herself saying yes when she really wanted to say no. When we come back, why we find it so hard to turn down requests and the effect this has on our well-being. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
杂货店离他们家只有五分钟路程。所以我认为这绝对影响了我与这位朋友的关系。像我们许多人一样，凡妮莎发现自己在想拒绝时却说了“是”。稍后回来，我们将探讨为什么我们发现拒绝请求如此困难，以及这对我们的幸福感有什么影响。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
All of us have been in situations where someone asks us for something. Sometimes the thing they want is easy for us to provide and we are happy to give it. Other times the request is outlandish but we still find it difficult to say no. At the University of Houston, Vanessa Patrick studies why we say yes when we really want to say no and the effects these choices have on our psychological health. Vanessa, you say there are important reasons we say yes when it would be better to say no, and the first has to do with our fears about the effect that saying no will have on our relationships. Can you say more about this?
我们所有人都经历过别人向我们寻求帮助的情况。有时他们想要的东西我们很容易提供，我们也乐于给予。另一些时候，请求很离谱，但我们仍然觉得很难说“不”。在休斯顿大学，凡妮莎·帕特里克研究了为什么我们在真正想说“不”时却说了“是”，以及这些选择对我们心理健康的影响。凡妮莎，你说我们之所以在最好说“不”的时候却说了“是”，有重要的原因，第一个与我们对拒绝会影响人际关系的恐惧有关。你能多说说吗？
Absolutely. So we are social creatures and we want to have strong connections with other people. And in order to maintain those connections and to maintain good relationships, we believe that we should say yes to the things that are asked of us. So you say that when someone makes a request of us, it's almost expected that we will say yes. So saying no is something that you call the socially dispreferred response.
当然。我们是社会性动物，我们希望与他人建立牢固的联系。为了维持这些联系和良好的人际关系，我们认为我们应该对别人的要求说“是”。所以你说，当有人向我们提出请求时，我们几乎被期望说“是”。所以说“不”被你称为“社会不偏好的回应”。
So besides our fears about relationships, there are all these social expectations that influence us. Absolutely. Saying no is a major harmony buster. People think that if you say no, people are really not going to like you, not going to invite you places, are not going to keep you as part of their social group. And this is something that as social creatures, we definitely try to avoid.
所以除了对人际关系的恐惧，还有所有这些影响我们的社会期望。绝对是这样。说“不”是破坏和谐的大忌。人们认为如果你说“不”，别人就不会喜欢你，不会邀请你参加活动，不会让你留在他们的社交圈里。作为社会性动物，我们绝对会尽量避免这种情况。
So a few years ago, Vanessa, we had another researcher named Vanessa on the show. This was psychologist Vanessa Barnes of Cornell University and her work showed that people say yes even to requests made by total strangers and even when the requests were completely out of line. You cited her work in some of your own research. Can you give me some examples of what she found? Yes, Vanessa Barnes' work is really fascinating and dovetails really well with my own. So Vanessa finds that people say yes to really the most crazy requests. She's had people do things like defile library books. Can I play soccer in your backyard?
几年前，凡妮莎，我们的节目里有另一位研究员也叫凡妮莎。她是康奈尔大学的心理学家凡妮莎·巴恩斯，她的研究表明，人们甚至会对完全陌生的人提出的请求说“是”，即使这些请求完全不合理。你在你的一些研究中引用了她的工作。你能给我举一些她发现的例子吗？是的，凡妮莎·巴恩斯的研究非常迷人，与我的研究非常契合。凡妮莎发现人们会对最疯狂的请求说“是”。她让人做过诸如损毁图书馆书籍之类的事情。我能在你的后院踢足球吗？
Can I borrow your credit card? And people are just like, sure, sure. And it's crazy to think about. But she finds robust effects that we are willing to go out of our way to say yes, because saying no comes so hard for us. So the concern we have for how other people will react shows up most clearly in relationships where we don't know the other person very well. You call this the acquaintance trap. What is the acquaintance trap, Vanessa? So the acquaintance trap is essentially the idea that when we have weak social ties with
我能借用你的信用卡吗？人们的反应只是，当然，当然。这想起来很疯狂。但她发现了强有力的证据，证明我们愿意为了说“是”而竭尽全力，因为说“不”对我们来说太难了。所以我们对他人反应的担忧在那些我们不太熟悉的人际关系中表现得最为明显。你称之为“熟人陷阱”。什么是“熟人陷阱”，凡妮莎？“熟人陷阱”本质上是指，当我们与人只有微弱的社会联系时，
people, we are most concerned about that relationship. So we worry about that relationship being most tenuous and most likely to be destroyed if we say no. So we get kind of trapped into saying yes to all these people who are acquaintances and oddly enough Shankar, the majority of people in our neighborhoods, in our communities, at our workplaces could be categorized as acquaintances. And they are the ones with whom we have the most struggle. Hmm. So in other words, if I know someone very well, they ask me for something and I say no to them, I'm reasonably confident that my relationship is secure enough that saying no is not going to damage my relationship. If someone is a total stranger and they ask me for something, I might be comfortable also saying no because
我们最担心那段关系。所以我们担心那段关系最脆弱，如果说“不”，最有可能被破坏。所以我们陷入了对所有这些熟人说“是”的陷阱，奇怪的是，尚卡尔，我们社区、邻里、工作场所中的大多数人都可以归类为熟人。而他们正是我们最难拒绝的人。嗯。换句话说，如果我非常了解某人，他们向我寻求帮助，我拒绝了他们，我有理由相信我的关系足够稳固，说“不”不会损害我们的关系。如果某人是完全的陌生人，他们向我寻求帮助，我也可能很自在地说“不”，因为
in fact I don't have a relationship with that person. It's the group of people who are in between who, as you point out, in fact are the vast majority of people whom we know that we have a really hard time saying no to. That is exactly right. And I'll tell you a really strange and interesting story about that. So one day, my daughter and I were driving back from a birthday party that she had just attended. Now, you know, these kids birthday parties where you play all morning, and then they give you lunch and then you head home. And so I watched her play and then I saw that she had ordered her favorite meal, which was chicken nuggets and fries. And we were heading home and she's and I thought,
事实上我和那个人没有关系。正是那些处于中间的人，正如你指出的，实际上是我们认识的绝大多数人，我们才真的很难对他们说“不”。完全正确。我给你讲一个关于这个的非常奇怪且有趣的故事。有一天，我和我女儿从她刚参加完的一个生日派对开车回来。你知道，这些孩子们的生日派对，你整个上午都在玩，然后他们给你午餐，然后你回家。我看着她玩，然后我看到她点了她最喜欢的餐点，鸡块和薯条。我们正要回家，她，我想，
okay, done. Now she can just play in the afternoon. I don't have to organize lunch. And she says, Mom, I'm hungry. I said, what? Why are you hungry? You just ate lunch. She said, No, I didn't. The girl next to me asked for my chicken nuggets and fries and I, you know, I didn't say no, I just gave them to her. And so I said, why did you give your chicken and nuggets and fries to somebody else and not eat your own lunch? And she said, it's the acquaintance trap mom. And I was just flabbergasted. She's obviously listening to me speak. This girl was in fact someone she had just met at that party.
好吧，结束了。现在她下午可以玩了。我不必准备午餐了。她说，妈妈，我饿了。我说，什么？你为什么饿了？你刚吃了午餐。她说，不，我没吃。我旁边的女孩要了我的鸡块和薯条，我，你知道，我没说不，我就给了她。所以我说，你为什么把你的鸡块和薯条给别人而不吃自己的午餐？她说，这是“熟人陷阱”，妈妈。我当时惊呆了。她显然在听我说话。那个女孩实际上是她在派对上刚认识的人。
And even at about nine years old, she was experiencing and recognized interestingly the acquaintance trap occurring in her own life. occurring in our own life. Another reason you say we say yes is that we're worried about the effect that saying no will have on our reputations and I'm wondering if this might have been one of the reasons you effectively said yes to your boss at that ad agency in India, which is you are worried what the effect of saying no would have on your reputation in your very first job.
即使在九岁左右，她也经历并有趣地认识到了发生在自己生活中的“熟人陷阱”。发生在我们的生活中。你说我们说“是”的另一个原因是担心说“不”会对我们的声誉产生影响，我想知道这是否是你实际上对你在印度那家广告公司的老板说“是”的原因之一，也就是你担心说“不”会对你在第一份工作中的声誉产生什么影响。
So reputation is a really key aspect of who we are as in organizations especially. So our reputation is what people say about us when we are not in the room. And we want people to say good things about us. We want people to say we are warm. We want people to say we are competent. We want people to say we are capable. And so we strive to create that impression in people's minds. And so saying no might come across as not being warm. Saying no in other situations could be she's not competent, she's not capable,
所以声誉确实是我们作为组织成员的一个关键方面。我们的声誉就是当我们不在房间里时别人对我们的评价。我们希望别人说我们的好话。我们希望别人说我们热情。我们希望别人说我们能干。我们希望别人说我们有能力。所以我们努力在人们心中创造那种印象。所以说“不”可能会被认为是不够热情。在其他情况下说“不”可能会被认为她不够能干，她不够有能力，
she can't juggle all the balls that everybody else is juggling. And that is definitely something that we are concerned about. You say that this concern about our reputation is often distilled into a single moment of being put on the spot. And you compare this to the cultural phenomenon known as the stadium proposal. What is the stadium proposal, Vanessa? So when people ask us something that we want to say no to, it feels as if the spotlight is on us and that everyone is stopped and waiting for us to say yes. And I liken that to the stadium proposal. And a stadium proposal is one of those
她无法处理每个人都在处理的所有事情。这绝对是我们所担心的。你说这种对声誉的担忧通常浓缩在被当众质问的那一刻。你将其与被称为“体育场求婚”的文化现象进行了比较。什么是“体育场求婚”，凡妮莎？所以当人们要求我们做一些我们想说“不”的事情时，感觉就像聚光灯打在我们身上，每个人都停下来等着我们说“是”。我将其比作“体育场求婚”。“体育场求婚”是那些
cultural phenomena where somebody proposes to the person that they love and it is broadcast on this big jumbotron screen in front of thousands and thousands of fans, typically at a sports event. typically at a sports event. And I talk about the fact that being in that stadium proposal moment, it's very hard to say no, if you think about it. The girl has very little choice. She can't say, you know, let me think about it. She is on the screen with everyone watching.
文化现象之一，某人向他们所爱的人求婚，并在成千上万的粉丝面前通过巨大的大屏幕广播，通常是在体育赛事中。通常是在体育赛事中。我谈到这样一个事实，即处于那种体育场求婚的时刻，如果你仔细想想，很难说“不”。那个女孩几乎没有选择。她不能说，你知道，让我考虑一下。她在大屏幕上，每个人都在看着。
And what I argue is that we have these mini stadium proposal moments that happen in our life on a daily basis. Someone asks you on an aircraft, can you please give up your aisle seat because I need to sit next to somebody? And your heart sinks because you have planned an aisle seat for months. Someone catches you on the corridor and asks you,
我所主张的是，我们的生活中每天都会发生这种微型的“体育场求婚”时刻。有人在飞机上问你，你能把你的过道座位让给我吗，因为我需要坐在某人旁边？你的心沉了下去，因为你几个月来一直计划着过道座位。有人在走廊拦住你问你，
can you please take this on? And then you just feel, do I really have a choice, especially if that person is your boss? And so these kind of mini stadium proposals really feel like the spotlight is on you and you have very little choice except to say yes. ["The Star-Spangled Banner"] You're drawing an analogy between what happens in the stadium and what happens to us in everyday
你能承担这个任务吗？然后你只是觉得，我真的有选择吗，特别是如果那个人是你的老板？所以这种微型的“体育场求婚”真的感觉聚光灯打在你身上，除了说“是”，你几乎没有选择。["星条旗"] 你在体育场发生的事情和我们在日常生活中发生的事情之间做了一个类比。
life. But of course, in everyday life, we know that there isn't a stadium watching us. We know that thousands of people are not watching us. We know that our faces are not on the jumbotron. Why does it feel that it is? Why does it feel as if the spotlight is on us, even when it's not? Absolutely. That's a great question, Shankar. And this stems from who we are as human beings. We have this egocentric bias, and the egocentric bias is that we believe that we are
但当然，在日常生活中，我们知道没有体育场在看着我们。我们知道成千上万的人没有在看着我们。我们知道我们的脸没有在大屏幕上。为什么感觉好像是这样？为什么感觉好像聚光灯打在我们身上，即使事实并非如此？绝对是这样，这是一个很好的问题，尚卡尔。这源于我们作为人类的本质。我们有这种自我中心偏差，自我中心偏差就是我们相信我们是
the center of attention. And I actually have a study in which I demonstrate the stadium proposal effect in the lab. This was a study I ran with undergraduates and I gave them a scenario in which I wanted to make sure that they were going to want to say no to this request that was coming their way. So I described a very busy semester and I described the fact that they have a ton of things that they have been busy with. And they were really, really looking for a spring break where they could just chill. So it was very clear that they wanted an open spring break. And then the Friday before spring break, they went to a party and met some people at a bar.
关注的中心。我实际上有一个研究，我在实验室中演示了“体育场求婚”效应。这是我和本科生进行的一项研究，我给他们一个场景，我想确保他们会想对即将到来的请求说“不”。所以我描述了一个非常忙碌的学期，我描述了他们一直忙于很多事情的事实。他们真的，真的在寻找一个可以放松的春假。所以很明显他们想要一个开放的春假。然后在春假前的周五，他们去参加了一个派对，在酒吧遇到了一些人。
And there was a person at the bar called Sarah. And Sarah kind of made an ask of the individual that they clearly would like to refuse. And the ask was that she was looking for volunteers to make 25 calls on behalf of a charity over spring break. So this was what everyone read. Then I varied the situation in different conditions. In one condition, which I call the solo ask condition. In the solo ask condition, Sarah asked this person just one-on-one, nobody watching. In the other condition,
酒吧里有一个人叫莎拉。莎拉对那个人提出了一个他们显然想拒绝的请求。请求是她正在寻找志愿者在春假期间代表慈善机构打25个电话。这就是每个人读到的内容。然后我在不同的条件下改变了情况。在一个我称之为“单独请求”的条件下。在“单独请求”条件下，莎拉一对一地问这个人，没有人看着。在另一个条件下，
which I call the social ask condition, there were a whole bunch of people already at the table who had also agreed to be part of this volunteer team for Sarah. So essentially, in one group, there was this more stadium proposal like experience where there are lots of people watching you and you are being asked to do something that you don't want to do. And then the solo ask where the other people disappear and it's just you. What I find interestingly, as you might imagine, because of the social pressure that is embedded in these situations, when people were asked one on one,
我称之为“社交请求”条件，桌子旁已经有一大群人也同意成为莎拉志愿者团队的一部分。所以本质上，在一个群体中，有这种更像“体育场求婚”的体验，有很多人看着你，你被要求做一些你不想做的事情。然后是“单独请求”，其他人消失了，只有你。有趣的是，正如你可能想象的那样，由于这些情况中嵌入的社会压力，当人们一对一地被问到时，
they were more likely and more comfortable with saying, no, I have plans for spring break and it does not involve making 25 calls. But when people were in the social ask condition, they were more likely to say yes to helping Sarah out. But what was also really interesting, Shankar, is the difference between men and women. In the social ask condition,
他们更有可能也更舒服地说，不，我有春假计划，不包括打25个电话。但当人们处于“社交请求”条件下时，他们更有可能对帮助莎拉说“是”。但同样非常有趣的是，尚卡尔，男性和女性之间的差异。在“社交请求”条件下，
both men and women felt equally uncomfortable with saying no. So it's a tough thing for anybody. But in the solo ask condition, where you took out the social pressure, it's much easier to say no to somebody who's asking you. Men felt comfortable with saying no more than women did. There was no difference for women between the solo-ass condition and the social-ass
男性和女性在说“不”时感到同样的不舒服。所以这对任何人来说都是一件难事。但在“单独请求”条件下，当你消除了社会压力时，拒绝向你提出请求的人要容易得多。男性比女性更舒服地说“不”。女性在“单独请求”条件和“社交请求”条件之间没有差异。
condition. It's almost like women conjure up an imaginary group who's watching them, and they feel extreme pressure to say yes, even when they wanna say no. So in other words, as for many women, it's almost as if they are on the jumbotron even when they're not. Absolutely. I'm thinking of this other story, and I don't know if the story is apocryphal, but it goes back to the days of World War II or the closing days of World War II.
这几乎就像女性召唤出一个想象中的群体在看着她们，即使在她们想说“不”的时候，她们也感到说“是”的巨大压力。所以换句话说，对于许多女性来说，就好像她们在大屏幕上，即使她们并不在。绝对是这样。我正在想另一个故事，我不知道这个故事是否是杜撰的，但它回到了二战时期或二战结束的日子。
days of World War II, you know, Japan was running out of ways to defend off attacks from the Allies and the Japanese military resorted to a number of kamikaze attacks where they basically had pilots basically fly their planes into enemy ships and essentially turn their planes into missiles. And if I remember the story correctly, the way they recruited people is they would line up people, you know, they would line up these pilots and basically say, does anyone not want to volunteer for these flights? You know, you can step forward and say, I don't want to do it, but you have to step forward in front of everybody else. And the moment you step forward in front of everybody else saying, I don't want to fly
二战的日子，你知道，日本在防御盟军攻击方面已经无计可施，日本军方采取了一些神风特攻队攻击，他们基本上让飞行员驾驶飞机撞向敌舰，本质上把他们的飞机变成了导弹。如果我没记错这个故事，他们招募人的方式是他们会排成一排，你知道，他们会排成这些飞行员，基本上说，有没有人不想自愿参加这些飞行任务？你知道，你可以站出来说，我不想做，但你必须在所有人面前站出来。当你站在所有人面前说，我不想飞
one of these suicide missions, everyone else knows that you have declined. And of course, what they found is hardly anyone would step forward to say they didn't want to do it. And what strikes me about that is that we care about our social reputation so intensely that it might go to a point where we're willing to die in order to protect our social reputations. Wow, that's a great story.
这些自杀任务之一时，其他人都会知道你已经拒绝了。当然，他们发现几乎没有人会站出来说他们不想做。让我印象深刻的是，我们对我们的社会声誉如此在意，以至于它可能会达到我们愿意为了保护我们的社会声誉而死的程度。哇，那是一个很棒的故事。
I've not heard that. And I think it's amplified in a society like Japan to protect our social reputations. Wow, that's a great story. I've not heard that. And I think it's amplified in a society like Japan where honor and interpersonal kind of connection is so strong. And I think you can see this amplified in collectivist cultures like Japan. in collectivist cultures like Japan. I strongly believe that individualistic cultures allow you the permission to say no more than collectivist cultures. In collectivist cultures, the power hierarchy,
我没听说过。我认为这在像日本这样的社会中被放大了，以保护我们的社会声誉。哇，那是一个很棒的故事。我没听说过。我认为这在像日本这样的社会中被放大了，那里荣誉和人际联系非常强烈。我认为你可以在像日本这样的集体主义文化中看到这种放大。在集体主义文化中。我坚信个人主义文化比集体主义文化更允许你说“不”。在集体主义文化中，权力等级，
the social connection, the expectation that you conform to society is so strong that I can totally see that this strategy, the non-volunteer strategy that the army used would work. Do you think the same thing might be happening with men and women, which is that if men are more individualistic on average and women tend to be more focused
社会联系，你必须顺从社会的期望是如此强烈，以至于我完全可以看出军队使用的这种策略，即非志愿者策略是有效的。你认为男性和女性之间可能也发生了同样的事情吗，即如果男性平均更个人主义，而女性平均更关注
on the community on average, and these are averages, of course, but if that's the case, do you think that might be driving the gender differences that we're seeing? That is definitely one of the reasons. In fact, there had been some research about why women are more likely to say yes to tasks, especially at the workplace. And they have found that it boils down to this communality. Women are expected to be more helpful, the nurturers, the givers in most relationships. And that stems from communality
社区，当然这些是平均值，但如果是这样的话，你认为这是否可能推动了我们看到的性别差异？这绝对是原因之一。事实上，关于为什么女性更有可能对任务说“是”，特别是在工作场所，已经有一些研究。他们发现这归结为这种共同性。女性被期望在大多数人际关系中更乐于助人，是培育者，是给予者。这源于共同性，
compared to men who is perfectly okay for them to be more agentic and more individualistic. So we often say yes when we want to say no, and you say that doing this often has the opposite effect of what we expect. So, for example, we say yes because we think that saying no will make us feel bad. You've run a study on this. What was your study and what did you find? So, I ran a study in which I asked people to give me stories, stories of times where they said yes when they wanted to say no, and other stories about when they said no successfully.
与男性相比，他们更具代理性和个人主义是完全可以的。所以我们经常在想说“不”时说“是”，你说这样做往往会产生与我们预期相反的效果。例如，我们说“是”是因为我们认为说“不”会让我们感觉不好。你对此进行了一项研究。你的研究是什么，你发现了什么？所以我进行了一项研究，我要求人们给我讲故事，关于他们在想说“不”时说了“是”的故事，以及关于他们成功说“不”的其他故事。
So I have two groups of stories, yes stories and no stories. And what I find, counter-intuitively, the people who say yes, they very often think that they will feel good about saying yes. And people who say no think that they are going to feel bad and guilty for saying no. What I find in reality is that people who say no feel way better than people who say yes when they wanted to say no. When you say no to things that you don't wanna do, you feel empowered, confident, in control. Whereas if you say yes when you wanna say no,
所以我有两个故事组，“是”的故事和“不”的故事。我发现，反直觉的是，那些说“是”的人，他们经常认为他们会因为说“是”而感觉良好。而那些说“不”的人认为他们会因为说“不”而感到糟糕和内疚。我实际上发现，说“不”的人比那些在想说“不”时说了“是”的人感觉好得多。当你对你不想做的事情说“不”时，你会感到被授权、自信、掌控。而如果你在想说“不”时说了“是”，
very often you feel really resentful towards the other person. You feel angry and frustrated. And that is something that is worth thinking about. That when we say yes to the things that we don't want to do, it often leaves us very grumpy, very unhappy and resentful to the other person. I mean, and this is along the lines of what happened with you and your friend when your friend asked you to pick up groceries and I think you wanted to say no, but you said yes.
你经常会对另一个人感到非常愤恨。你会感到愤怒和沮丧。这是值得思考的事情。当我们对我们不想做的事情说“是”时，它往往会让我们非常暴躁、非常不快乐，并对另一个人感到愤恨。我的意思是，这和你与你的朋友发生的事情是一样的，当你的朋友让你去买杂货时，我想你想说“不”，但你说了“是”。
You know, and then you showed up and found your friend's husband was in the garden drinking beer. You didn't just feel like I shouldn't have spent the last two hours doing something I didn't want to do. You said that it actually damaged your relationship with your friends. So in other words, saying yes when we want to say no
你知道，然后你出现了，发现你朋友的丈夫在花园里喝啤酒。你不仅觉得我不应该花过去两个小时做我不想做的事情。你说这实际上损害了你与朋友的关系。所以换句话说，在想说“不”时说“是”
is not just bad for us personally, it's actually bad for our relationships. 100%. I actually do this exercise in my class, which I call the stinking pile of garbage exercise. And saying yes to something that you don't want to do is like taking on a stinking pile of garbage. As soon as you say yes,
不仅对我们个人不好，实际上对我们的人际关系也不好。100%。我实际上在我的课上做这个练习，我称之为“臭垃圾堆练习”。对你不想做的事情说“是”就像承担了一堆臭垃圾。一旦你说了“是”，
now it is your stinking pile of garbage that you have to deal with. And that is something that can make us very grumpy and resentful and unhappy in general. You point out that one reason some of us might say yes to a request is that we say, okay, it's just this one time, this friend wants me to pick up groceries
现在这就是你必须处理的臭垃圾堆。这会让我们在一般情况下变得非常暴躁、愤恨和不快乐。你指出，我们中的一些人可能对请求说“是”的一个原因是，我们说，好吧，只是这一次，这个朋友想让我去买杂货
just this one time. I'm just gonna do this one thing and then we'll just get this unpleasant task over with. It's gonna be three hours out of my day, but it's not going to happen again. And so we tell ourselves a little story that we can essentially placate the person who is making this unreasonable request
只是这一次。我只是要做这一件事，然后我们就会把这个不愉快的任务处理掉。这会占用我一天中的三个小时，但它不会再发生了。所以我们给自己讲了一个小故事，我们可以本质上安抚那个提出这个不合理请求的人，
and the request won't be repeated. Can you talk about why that idea might be a misguided idea, Vanessa? Yes, absolutely. I talk about this notion of the psychological immune system, which is the coping, the set of coping responses that come into play whenever we have to deal with something unpleasant. And so there are these unpleasant things like, say, picking up groceries and
并且这个请求不会被重复。你能谈谈为什么这个想法可能是一个误导性的想法吗，凡妮莎？是的，绝对是。我谈到了心理免疫系统的概念，即每当我们不得不处理不愉快的事情时，就会发挥作用的一套应对反应。所以有这些不愉快的事情，比如，说去买杂货和
spending three hours doing it. And we come up with these reasons why it's okay. And unfortunately for us, when we come up with excuses and when we invoke this psychological immune system and our coping mechanisms kick in, we are less likely to learn from our mistakes. So if you see someone who keeps making the same mistakes again and again and again, it's because the coping mechanism has kicked in and they have failed to learn from the experience.
花三个小时去做。我们想出了这些理由，为什么这样做没关系。不幸的是，当我们想出借口，当我们调用这个心理免疫系统，我们的应对机制发挥作用时，我们就不太可能从错误中学习。所以如果你看到有人不断地重复同样的错误，那是因为应对机制已经发挥作用，他们未能从经验中学习。
I mean, it's an interesting thing because you're pointing out here that our ability to forecast how we will feel, we forecast that I will feel happy if I say yes and I will feel bad if I say no. You've shown that that forecast is inaccurate. So in other words, we are bad at forecasting. But once we've done something, you're also pointing out that we're bad at learning. So in other words, there's sort of this pincer movement where on both sides of the experience were either inaccurate in our forecast or inaccurate in learning from what just happened.
我的意思是，这是一件有趣的事情，因为你在这里指出，我们预测我们将如何感受的能力，我们预测如果我说“是”我会感到快乐，如果我说“不”我会感到糟糕。你已经证明这种预测是不准确的。所以换句话说，我们不善于预测。但一旦我们做了某事，你也指出我们不善于学习。所以换句话说，有一种钳形运动，在体验的两端，我们要么在预测中不准确，要么在从刚刚发生的事情中学习时不准确。
So we are definitely inaccurate in our forecast and there's quite a lot of research by Tim Wilson and Dan Gilbert on affective forecasting. But the learning is something that we can actually put things in place to prevent. We can definitely invest more in self-reflection, invest more in learning from those experiences. So I very often advise, when you make a mistake, dwell on it. Feel bad, recognize that this was not something that you want to do. Make a personal policy or some sort of decision around it so that you are able to not repeat that mistake again.
所以我们绝对在预测中不准确，蒂姆·威尔逊和丹·吉尔伯特关于情感预测的研究非常多。但学习是我们实际上可以采取措施来防止的事情。我们绝对可以更多地投资于自我反思，更多地投资于从这些经验中学习。所以我经常建议，当你犯错时，要深思。感到糟糕，认识到这不是你想做的事情。围绕它制定个人政策或某种决定，以便你能够不再重复那个错误。
Besides looking at the fact that we often say yes when we want to say no, you also examine how we say no when we turn down requests. And you find that even when we turn down requests, we often do so poorly and in fact we often sabotage ourselves. For example, we offer what you call a compromise no. What is a compromise no, Vanessa? If you say something like, no, but if you really want me to, I'll do it, that's not a no. That's a yes. People are trying to be nice. I get it.
除了关注我们经常在想说“不”时说“是”的事实外，你还研究了我们拒绝请求时如何说“不”。你发现即使我们拒绝请求，我们往往也做得不好，事实上我们经常破坏自己。例如，你提供了一种你称之为“妥协的拒绝”。什么是“妥协的拒绝”，凡妮莎？如果你说类似的话，不，但如果你真的想让我做，我会做的，那不是拒绝。那是“是”。人们试图变得友善。我明白。
It's this way of saying no that's very nice. You know, I really can't do it. But if you really, really wanted me to, I would. That's kind of a compromise, right? I don't want to help, but I want to help. So you're kind of in that really weird place. What I also find is that people very often say no in a way that signals that I'm open to be persuaded otherwise. So there's a lot about the body language, it's the way the no is said that says, hey, you know, I could be convinced.
这是一种非常友善的说“不”的方式。你知道，我真的做不到。但如果你真的，真的想让我做，我会的。那是一种妥协，对吧？我不想帮忙，但我想帮忙。所以你处于那种非常奇怪的地方。我还发现，人们经常以一种暗示我愿意被说服的方式说“不”。所以有很多关于肢体语言，说“不”的方式说，嘿，你知道，我可以被说服。
You said that another unproductive way of saying no was dramatized in the 1999 movie The Runaway Bride featuring Julia Roberts. I haven't seen this movie, Vanessa. What is it about? What happens? Yeah, I'm a huge fan of these kind of movies. So what happens with Julia Roberts as a character is that she is someone who's the classic people pleaser. She doesn't really have a mind of her own. She doesn't have any preferences of her own.
你说另一种非生产性的说“不”的方式在1999年的电影《落跑新娘》中被戏剧化了，由朱莉娅·罗伯茨主演。我没看过这部电影，凡妮莎。它是关于什么的？发生了什么？是的，我是这类电影的忠实粉丝。所以朱莉娅·罗伯茨作为角色的情况是，她是一个典型的讨好者。她没有自己的主见。她没有任何自己的偏好。
She just does whatever the person she's with wants to do. So the story without giving away too much is essentially she's the runaway bride. She's lovely, people wanna marry her and she keeps meeting these different guys and going up until the altar, but then can't commit. And with each of these relationships, she has essentially agreed to do whatever they
她总是顺从身边人的意愿。如果不剧透太多，故事的核心就是她是一个逃跑的新娘。她很可爱，人们都想娶她，她不断遇到不同的男人，一直走到祭坛前，却无法做出承诺。在每一段关系中，她基本上都同意去做对方
wanted. And so it's just at the moment where she was going to say yes to this marriage that she runs away because she just doesn't feel that this is something that works for her. And so it's a really interesting thing that there are, that we can get ourselves into situations where we say yes and yes and yes and yes and then you know something disastrous happens and then we just make some big move and say no like quit our job or leave the person at the altar. So in other words because we are not able to say no in lower stakes settings what you're saying is that the
想要做的事。就在她即将答应这场婚姻的时刻，她逃跑了，因为她觉得这并不适合她。这是一个非常有趣的现象，我们有时会陷入一种境地：不断地说“好、好、好”，然后发生了一些灾难性的事情，我们就会做出重大举动说“不”，比如辞职或在婚礼上抛下对方。换句话说，因为我们在低风险的情况下无法说“不”，你的意思是
pressure eventually builds up and then the pressure cooker basically blows and then we're exploding at the other person and saying you know you take me for granted or you never understand me or you're an unkind person and the other person looks at us bewildered saying why don't you just say no you could have said no like you know two years ago and I think that's what you're getting at that in some ways our inability to say no in small circumstances prompts us then to explode into a gigantic no in a way that's also inappropriate. I think that happens mostly with me as a parent. You know you want to be a good mom so you say yes
压力最终会累积，压力锅最终会爆炸，然后我们对另一个人发火，说“你把我的付出视为理所当然”或者“你从不理解我”或者“你是个刻薄的人”。而对方会困惑地看着我们说：“你为什么不早点说不呢？你两年前就可以说了。”我想这就是你所指出的：在某种程度上，我们在小事上无法说“不”，导致我们最终以一种不恰当的方式爆发出一个巨大的“不”。我觉得作为父母，这种情况在我身上发生得最多。你知道，你想做一个好妈妈，所以你一直说
yes yes yes yes and then becomes so much and you're so tired and then sometimes you just explode. How do we say no in a way that preserves relationships and protects our reputation? When we come back, the art and science of empowered refusals. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. At the University of Houston, Vanessa Patrick studies why we say yes when we want to say no, and how to align what we do with what we want to do. She's the author of the book, The Power of Saying No, the new science of how to say no
好、好、好，然后负担变得太重，你太累了，有时你就会爆发。我们该如何以一种既能维护关系又能保护声誉的方式说“不”呢？休息之后，我们将探讨赋权拒绝的艺术与科学。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。在休斯顿大学，凡妮莎·帕特里克（Vanessa Patrick）研究我们为何在想说“不”时却说了“好”，以及如何将我们的行为与我们的意愿保持一致。她是《说“不”的力量：说“不”的新科学》一书的作者，这本书
that puts you in charge of your life. Vanessa, I understand that you have a book on your shelf in your office, the title of which you try to keep in your line of sight when you're on the phone or looking up from your computer. What is this book? So it is a book called Hell Yes, Two Little Words for a Simpler Happier Life. The important takeaway from the book is
让你掌控自己的生活。凡妮莎，我听说你办公室的书架上有一本书，当你打电话或从电脑前抬头时，你会尽量让书名保持在视线范围内。那是什么书？那是一本名为《绝对的好：让生活更简单、更快乐的两个词》的书。这本书的重要启示是
that if it is not a hell yes, it is a hell no. And it's a very simple idea that you have to know what's a hell yes for you and say yes to those things and hell no to everything else. You say that the first step in saying no well is deciding when to say it and you say whenever we receive a request for our time and energy, we should engage in something that you call strategic postponement. What is strategic postponement Vanessa? Strategic postponement is essentially this idea that we shouldn't make a decision in the heat of the moment We are more likely When we are one-on-one with someone and they ask us in the moment to say yes.
如果不是“绝对的好”，那就是“绝对的不好”。这是一个非常简单的理念：你必须知道什么是对你来说“绝对的好”，对这些事情说“好”，对其他所有事情说“绝对的不好”。你说，学会说“不”的第一步是决定何时说“不”，你说每当我们收到关于时间和精力的请求时，我们应该进行一种你称之为“战略性推迟”的行为。什么是战略性推迟，凡妮莎？战略性推迟本质上是这样一种理念：我们不应该在冲动之下做出决定。当我们与某人一对一，而他们当场要求我们答应时，我们更有可能
We are much more likely to say yes in those situations. And that is because we are in a hot state. So essentially strategic postponement would be postponing to the future when we are in a colder state to be able to make a decision with more information, having thought through it. You say that a helpful tool here may be with more information, having thought through it. You say that a helpful tool here may be to develop personal policies.
在那种情况下说“好”。这是因为我们处于一种“热状态”。所以，战略性推迟本质上是将决定推迟到未来，当我们处于“冷状态”时，能够带着更多信息、经过深思熟虑后再做出决定。你说这里的一个有用工具可能是制定个人准则。
What are personal policies? I've heard of organizational policies and company policies. What are personal policies? Personal policies are simple rules that we set up for ourselves that guide our actions and decisions. And these rules are based on who we are. They stem from our identity.
什么是个人准则？我听说过组织准则和公司准则。什么是个人准则？个人准则是我们为自己设定的简单规则，用以指导我们的行动和决策。这些规则基于我们是谁。它们源于我们的身份。
They give voice to our values and priorities and preferences and beliefs. They essentially shape how we choose to live our lives. And if we come up with policies about and rules that help us make these decisions, we have an infrastructure, we have a framework that gives us the ability to say no more effectively. You say that the novelist Isabel Allende
它们表达了我们的价值观、优先事项、偏好和信仰。它们本质上塑造了我们选择生活的方式。如果我们制定了有助于我们做出这些决定的准则和规则，我们就拥有了一个基础设施，一个框架，使我们能够更有效地拒绝。你说小说家伊莎贝尔·阿连德（Isabel Allende）
has a set of personal policies that help her focus on her writing. What are these policies, Vanessa? So if you think about Isabel Allende, she has spent a lot of time thinking about What value she brings to the world and she has identified that the central contribution that she makes Despite the many many things that she does for making films to philanthropic engagements, etc
有一套帮助她专注于写作的个人准则。这些准则是什么，凡妮莎？如果你想到伊莎贝尔·阿连德，她花了很多时间思考她为世界带来了什么价值，她确定了她所做出的核心贡献，尽管她做了很多很多事情，从制作电影到慈善活动等等
At the end of the day everything stems from writing, and she needs to make time for writing in order for her to do the other things. So she ruthlessly prioritizes her writing. And the way she does it is by having a start date every year to start a new writing project. So in 1981, she started writing a letter which converted into a book called House of Spirits. And that book started on the 8th of January. And so since then, every year on the 8th of January, she starts a new book. And she's got that discipline to say, 8th of Jan, all the other engagements have to go away.
归根结底，一切都源于写作，她需要为写作腾出时间，以便去做其他事情。所以她无情地优先考虑她的写作。她的做法是每年设定一个开始日期来启动新的写作项目。1981年，她开始写一封信，后来变成了一本名为《幽灵之家》的书。那本书始于1月8日。从那时起，每年的1月8日，她都会开始写一本新书。她有那种纪律性，说：“1月8日，所有其他事务都必须推开。”
I'm just going to sit down and do my writing. And she has a very rigorous writing schedule. She writes every day for many hours. And that is kind of how she contributes to the world. More importantly, is that everyone knows that she is unavailable after the 8th of January. And so they don't ask her to do stuff either. And that is how you invoke a personal policy and put it into action. You have a policy which is your rule. I start on the 8th of January. You share that policy with people so that they know that that is your policy.
我只是坐下来进行写作。她有一个非常严格的写作时间表。她每天写作好几个小时。这就是她为世界做出贡献的方式。更重要的是，每个人都知道她在1月8日之后是不可用的。所以他们也不会要求她做其他事情。这就是你如何调用个人准则并将其付诸实践。你有一个准则，也就是你的规则：我从1月8日开始。你与人们分享这个准则，让他们知道这是你的准则。
And they don't ask you stuff that violates that policy. Vanessa says that when people make requests of her, she divides them into two buckets. Things that are easy or things that are difficult for her. But then she also asks, does this request offer marginal benefit or substantial benefit to the other person? Things that are easy to do and very helpful to someone else, those should be automatic yeses. Things that are of trivial importance to the requester, those should be automatic no's regardless of how much effort they involve. The trickiest requests have to do with things that are difficult for us to do but are immensely meaningful to us and to the recipient. Many books and movies are about characters fulfilling such requests.
他们就不会要求你做违反该准则的事情。凡妮莎说，当人们向她提出请求时，她会将它们分为两类：对她来说容易的事情或困难的事情。但她还会问：这个请求对对方来说是边际利益还是实质利益？容易做到且对他人非常有帮助的事情，应该自动答应。对请求者来说微不足道的事情，无论涉及多少努力，都应该自动拒绝。最棘手的请求与那些对我们来说很难做到，但对我们和接收者来说意义重大的事情有关。许多书籍和电影都是关于角色完成此类请求的。
Vanessa calls these the hero's journey asks. These are asks that make life worthwhile and meaningful because we are able to bring our best selves to these tasks. They showcase our unique talent. They create value. These are things that we should They showcase our unique talent. They create value. These are things that we should be spending our time on. This is what builds reputation and grows relationships. So we should say yes,
凡妮莎称这些为“英雄之旅”式的请求。这些请求让生活变得有价值和有意义，因为我们能够将最好的自己投入到这些任务中。它们展示了我们独特的才能。它们创造了价值。这些是我们应该投入时间的事情。这就是建立声誉和发展关系的方式。所以我们应该说“好”，
and we should have space in our days to say yes to the hero's journey asks. So in other words, someone says, you know, do you want to come and volunteer in another country for two years working in difficult circumstances? And you say that would be an enormous ask on my time, but in fact it would be very meaningful to do. That could be an example of something that gives your life meaning. Or, you know, let's say you're thinking about having a child and raising a child involves significant time and effort and sacrifice,
我们应该在日常生活中留出空间来答应“英雄之旅”式的请求。换句话说，有人说：“你想去另一个国家做两年的志愿者，在困难的环境下工作吗？”你说那会占用我大量的时间，但实际上这样做非常有意义。这可能是一个赋予你生活意义的例子。或者，假设你正在考虑生孩子，抚养孩子涉及大量的时间、精力和牺牲，
but it's also profoundly meaningful. And what you're saying is we need to decide on the things that are meaningful to us. And those are the domains where in fact, we should be willing to say yes to things that are in fact, extraordinarily difficult and costly. Yes, absolutely. It's so funny Shankar, because people think because I wrote this book,
但它也具有深刻的意义。你的意思是我们需要决定什么对我们有意义。这些领域实际上是我们应该愿意对那些极其困难和代价高昂的事情说“好”的地方。是的，绝对是。尚卡尔，这很有趣，因为人们认为因为我写了这本书，
I'm the queen of no, and that I just go around saying no willy nilly. And that is not at all the reality. It's much more that I'm extremely strategic and thoughtful about what I say yes to, what I commit to, and what I say no to. There are things I will not touch and then things I fully immerse myself in. So we've been talking Vanessa about making the decision about when to say no. Once we've decided that no in fact is the correct answer, there is still the matter of how we can say no well. And you say that we should put our no
我是“拒绝女王”，我到处随意地说“不”。事实完全不是这样。更多的是，我对答应什么、承诺什么以及拒绝什么极其有策略和深思熟虑。有些事情我绝不触碰，而有些事情我则全身心投入。所以，凡妮莎，我们一直在谈论关于何时说“不”的决定。一旦我们决定“不”确实是正确的答案，仍然存在如何很好地说“不”的问题。你说我们应该把我们的“不”
in the form of something you call an empowered refusal. What is an empowered refusal? An empowered refusal is a way of saying no that stems from your identity. So what I found in my research is that when you look inwards and ground your no based on who you are and the extent to which the no reflects your values, your authentic self. When you communicate a no from that place, you come across as much more determined and with greater conviction and are less likely
以你所称的“赋权拒绝”的形式表达出来。什么是赋权拒绝？赋权拒绝是一种源于你身份的说“不”的方式。我在研究中发现，当你向内看，并基于你是谁以及这个“不”在多大程度上反映了你的价值观和真实的自我来支撑你的“不”时。当你从那个立场传达一个“不”时，你会显得更加坚定，更有信念，也更不容易
to get pushback from other people. So one way in which this empowered refusal can manifest itself is in the language we use to communicate our refusals. You recommend that we use the phrase, I don't, rather than the phrase, I can't. Why is this, Vanessa? When you say, I don't, you are signaling that this is who you are, that it stems from your identity, and hence gives your refusal much more power. It puts you in the driver's seat of your own life.
受到他人的阻力。所以，这种赋权拒绝的一种表现方式是我们用来传达拒绝的语言。你建议我们使用“我不……”这样的短语，而不是“我不能……”。为什么会这样，凡妮莎？当你使用“我不……”时，你是在发出信号，表明这就是你，它源于你的身份，因此赋予了你的拒绝更大的力量。它让你坐在自己生活的驾驶座上。
It essentially says, I know that this is a no for me, and it's an unwavering stance. In contrast, and very commonly used, just to look for an excuse and say, I'm sorry, I can't. I can't very often begs the question, why not? And then you get into all the external reasons as to why you are unable to take this on. And it opens a discussion and it invites negotiation. What I've shown in my research is that when you say, I don't, you shut that down. You essentially say, this is my way. This is what I believe. And people don't argue with who you are.
它本质上是在说：“我知道这对我是个‘不’，这是一个坚定不移的立场。”相比之下，人们非常常用的一种寻找借口的方式是说：“对不起，我不能。”“我不能”往往会引出“为什么不能？”的问题，然后你就会陷入所有关于你为什么无法承担此事的外部原因中。这开启了一场讨论，并邀请了谈判。我的研究表明，当你使用“我不……”时，你就切断了这种可能。你本质上是在说：“这是我的方式。这是我的信仰。”人们不会去争论你是谁。
and people don't argue with who you are. You say that it's also best to avoid giving excuses when we say no. What do you mean by this and how do you operationalize this, Vanessa? So we have learned that when we want to say no, we often lean on an excuse. I ran an experiment where people read a scenario that they were looking to borrow $1,500 from a friend. And their friend in different situations told them different things. In one situation where the friend invoked a personal policy,
人们不会去争论你是谁。你说在说“不”时最好避免找借口。你是什么意思，凡妮莎，你如何将其付诸实践？我们已经了解到，当我们想说“不”时，我们往往会依赖借口。我做了一个实验，人们阅读了一个场景：他们想向朋友借1500美元。他们的朋友在不同的情况下告诉了他们不同的事情。在一种情况下，朋友援引了个人准则，
the friend essentially said, I'm sorry, I'm not going to loan you the money, which essentially said this is my policy about loaning money to friends. Compared to the excuse where the friend essentially said, I'm really sorry, I can't give you the money because I need to use that money that I'm saving up for graduate school. What I asked people was whether the refusal was effective. In both cases, the refusal was effective. In the sense, people went away and said, okay, fine, I'm not getting the money. The critical thing I was looking at was whether 10 years from now, you need money again, would you go back and ask that friend for money?
朋友本质上说：“对不起，我不会借给你钱。”这本质上是在说这是我关于借钱给朋友的准则。相比之下，在那个找借口的例子中，朋友本质上说：“真的很抱歉，我不能给你钱，因为我需要用那笔钱来支付研究生的学费。”我问人们的是，这种拒绝是否有效。在这两种情况下，拒绝都是有效的。从某种意义上说，人们离开了并说：“好吧，我没借到钱。”我关注的关键点是，如果10年后你再次需要钱，你还会回去问那个朋友借钱吗？
And as you might imagine, when somebody used the excuse, something that was temporary, something that was external to them, people said, yeah, I'll ask that friend because presumably, they've paid for graduate school. When the person invoked a personal policy, people were less likely, significantly less likely to go back and ask them for money. So a personal policy essentially just conveys your stance on a matter and shuts the door, not only in the moment, but for the long run. only in the moment, but for the long run. So beyond simply getting out of tasks that we'd rather not spend our time on, what I think I'm really hearing from you
正如你所料，当有人使用借口时，即某种暂时的、外部的原因，人们说：“是的，我会问那个朋友，因为大概他们已经付完学费了。”当那个人援引个人准则时，人们回去问他们借钱的可能性显著降低。所以，个人准则本质上只是传达了你在某事上的立场，并关上了大门，不仅是在当下，而且是在长远来看。所以，除了简单地摆脱我们不想花时间处理的任务之外，我想我真正从你这里听到的是，
Vanessa is that the power to say no is central to carving out our own destiny. Learning to say no is part of defining who we are and what we want out of life. I absolutely agree. Absolutely. I think that how we spend our days is how we spend our lives. And so the things that we spend our time on on a daily basis adds up to how we spend our lives. So I agree with you that saying no is very much about creating the destiny that we want for ourselves.
凡妮莎，说“不”的力量对于开创我们自己的命运至关重要。学会说“不”是定义我们是谁以及我们想要从生活中得到什么的一部分。我完全同意。绝对同意。我认为我们如何度过每一天就是我们如何度过一生。所以我们每天花时间做的事情加起来就是我们如何度过一生。所以我同意你的观点，说“不”在很大程度上是为了创造我们想要的命运。
Vanessa Patrick is a professor of marketing at the University of Houston. She's the author of the book, The Power of Saying No, the new science of how to say no that puts you in charge of your life. Vanessa, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. This was so much fun. If you have follow-up questions for Vanessa Patrick that you'd be willing to share with members of the Hidden Brain audience, please find a quiet space, record a voice memo on your phone, and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Sixty seconds
凡妮莎·帕特里克是休斯顿大学的市场营销学教授。她是《说“不”的力量：说“不”的新科学》一书的作者，这本书让你掌控自己的生活。凡妮莎，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。这太有趣了。如果你有想问凡妮莎·帕特里克的问题，并且愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享，请找一个安静的地方，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录，并发送电子邮件至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再次重复那个电子邮件地址：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。六十秒
is plenty, and please use the subject line, saying no. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For more Hidden Brain, please consider joining our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus. It's where you'll find interviews and ideas that you won't find anywhere else, plus your
足够了，请使用主题行“说不”（saying no）。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·奎雷尔（Laura Quirell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅《隐藏的大脑 Plus》（Hidden Brain Plus）。在那里你会找到你在其他任何地方都找不到的采访和观点，此外你的
membership is a great way to support our work. You can try Hidden Brain Plus with a free 7-day trial by going to support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
会员资格是支持我们工作的绝佳方式。你可以通过访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.co/hiddenbrain 免费试用《隐藏的大脑 Plus》7天。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。